tu as picolé pour ce film alors oui je
suis picole
bonsoir ton père était militaire de
carrière tu es né en Allemagne
d'ailleurs il déménageait sans arrêt
c'est vrai ça a souffert de ça
[Musique]
je sais pas j'ai peut-être pour ça que
j'ai une vision du monde un peu je me
sens pas attachée forcément une région
très précise quand tu avais 4 ans il est
parti faire la guerre en Indochine ça
marqué ça tu te rendais compte de ce
qu'il allait faire par la suite ça m'a
marqué après c'est la relation avec Lui
qui a été difficile en l'été vous alliez
en vacances à Saint-Georges-de-Didonne
il faisait des Super 8
sérieusement en plus
amateur éclairé et passionné de cinéma
donc il faisait des il y a écrit des
histoires il faisait découpage et puis
les tournées donc avec mes frères mes
sœurs les cousins etc la famille les
tentent comme on a fait une vingtaine de
courts métrages qui sont en plus assez
bien fait avec des avec des effets
spéciaux avec il faisait tout lui-même
il éclairage le montage le mixage je me
souviens le mixage pendant qu'on se
retrouver un appartement comme ça à
faire avec
moi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai repris un peu l'idée de
donc il avait repris des idées comme ça
de film illustre et puis il avait fait
avec ses enfants donc on avait tourné
pendant finalement pendant 10 ans moi
j'ai tous les étés je me suis retrouvé
sur un plateau alors après vous avez
quand même retrouvé en droit sciences
éco ça rigolait moins marrant c'est pas
plus c'était bon à ça c'est pas
forcément je sais pas depuis je suis pas
mis j'ai pas mis les pieds maintenant
j'ai passé deux ans
dans une maison un peu bizarre comment
tu as décidé d'aller rue Blanche
la rue Blanche j'ai quitté j'ai quitté à
un moment donné j'ai fermé la porte
je choisis ma vie quoi je suis
responsable de ma vie j'ai pas vivre ce
que les gens ont décidé de me faire
vivre de me faire vivre donc j'ai décidé
de vivre à mes risques et périls et donc
j'ai décidé de je me suis inscrit dans
les cours de Raymond Girard rue Vavin à
l'époque après je suis rentré
rub-blanche et puis là les choses ont
commencé là j'ai passé deux ans avec des
et des copains que je revois encore
aujourd'hui après tu as eu sa période
théâtre Elisabeth donc après je suis
rentré dans une troupe comme ça on avait
du théâtre élisabethin avec une metteur
en scène américain qui débarquait lui
aussi donc c'était des gens qui histoire
sale et puis on a monté quatre pièces
elisabethen tu as eu cette période tu as
passé trois ans
enfermé chez toi méditation retraite
c'est incroyable ça
bouquiner
des auteurs parce que j'avais le
sentiment de pas connaître grand chose
et donc je me suis j'ai plongé dans les
littérature
la musique je me suis mis à plein de
choses je dis souvent dans les
interviews comme ça tu parles des
lectures de cette époque était un des
trucs
on en parle à chaque fois on cite la
liste des livres que tu as lu comme si
c'était exceptionnel en disant je suis
passionné pour des mais je suis
passionné pour des auteurs je suis
passionné pour Flaubert mais je me suis
passionné pour pour ce qu'il a écrit
puis je me suis passionné pour l'homme
et alors tu as mis trois ans à
comprendre que que personne n'aurait te
chercher quoi tu pouvais rester 30 ans
tu as décidé de sortir tu as fait quoi
quand tu es sorti de cette retraite j'ai
fait j'ai réalisé quelque chose tu vois
j'ai réalisé un court-métrage tu as eu
un prix de la qualité du CNC quand même
la vision d'un moi je débarque à Cannes
je connaissais pas Cannes je connaissais
très peu de cinéma et j'ai débarqué
la-bas et c'était vraiment au bluff quoi
j'ai vraiment déambuler je me suis dit
l'histoire d'un personnage qui débarque
et qui essaie de vendre son fils sa
vision du festival et c'est une vision
un peu bizarre et un peu
original du festival et de ceux qui
essayent et qui est inqui aspire à
rentrer dans ce monde
assez magique assez
ému des gens qui existent à travers les
projecteurs et puis dès que les
projecteurs s'éteignent ton premier film
c'était family rock tu as eu un César 83
il commence très fort toujours quand
même et après tu as fait tout un tas de
films qu'elles sont ceux dont tu veux te
souvenir la rencontre avec Michel devise
a été un moment important
du public parce que un acteur
la femme de ma vie
que les mulets on a raconté
dans le rôle mais en même temps on a
raconté beaucoup de choses que je veux
m'imbiber etc mais finalement je crois
que
ce qui est bien avec un acteur c'est
quelqu'un qui a un pouvoir d'imagination
et un pouvoir pour à partir d'un verre
de blanc le matin je voulais l'alcoolo
toute la journée voilà le matin quand il
s'agissait de tourner une scène un peu
difficile j'avais besoin j'avais besoin
d'un petit goût quoi le goût de l'alcool
j'ai pas besoin d'être un bébé parce que
si il faut être imbibé complètement s'il
faut pardonne 10 litres d'alcool pour
être l'alcoolique c'est pas la peine
d'être acteur voilà tu viens de tourner
un gros truc qui s'appelle jean-galmo
aventurier 70 millions et combien de
semaines de tournage 15 ou 16 non oh oui
il y a près de 20 semaines de tournage
ça dure 2h20
très très gros film mais grosse enfin
aventure exceptionnelle Sandra en a
parlé de ce personnage également donc tu
as retrouvé le Sandra de ta de ta
méditation et que tu as ta retraite aux
gens qu'elle mot c'était
une histoire un journaliste vous êtes
bien un journaliste au départ c'est vrai
que Blais standard s'en a parlé c'était
le seul qui en a parlé c'est vrai que
les gens Galmot aujourd'hui personne ne
me connaît donc c'est un c'est un vrai
héros un héros du début du siècle je
suis parti là-bas un journaliste qui
avait trempé un peu dans l'affaire
Dreyfus c'était un dreyfusard et j'avais
apporté
la preuve d'innocence qui avait apporté
la preuve de l'innocence de Dreyfus et
donc on a essayé de le je crois qu'on a
essayé de lui dire de
l'exil un petit peu de lui dire de
prendre des vacances
et donc il est parti en Guyane là-bas
avec un titre de propriété pour chercher
de l'or sur un placeur là-bas et il a
trouvé de l'or mais comme c'était un
homme brillant assez intelligent doué de
multiples talents il a trouvé de l'or
avec cette heure-là il a acheté la canne
à sucre après il a acheté du bois de
rose il a fait du Balata du caoutchouc
il a eu 40 bâtons il a fait fortune
c'est une des plus grandes fortunes
d'Europe et après donc il a surtout
déstabilisé la colonie là-bas des
grandes compagnies coloniales qui
étaient en place il les a déstabilisés
et surtout il a rencontré un peuple le
peuple Guyonnais qu'il a le peuple qui
l'a complètement adopté et qu'il a
poussé à la députation il s'est présenté
pour être député de la Guyane et là on
commençait un peu ses ennuis parce qu'on
a essayé de le ruiner de le casser de la
liste il voulait libérer qui a essayé de
libérer d'affranchir tout le peuple
Guiné tous les noirs là-bas donc c'était
un blanc mais il était avec il a voulu
affranchir les tous les noirs de
l'esclavage politique dans lequel ils
étaient depuis pas mal de temps et
c'était un c'était un poète c'était un
1600 en septembre en octobre ça sort le
24 octobre et alors aujourd'hui au
Palais de Tokyo dans le cadre de la Fête
du cinéma on a passé une petite séquence
qui était voilà on peut y voir une
petite séquence une petite séquence et
qui donne un peu un avant-goût comme ça
une idée d'un peu de l'ampleur et de la
de l'émotion qui qui a dans ce film là
et
donc dans le cadre de la Fête du Cinéma
qui en plus cette année je crois ah oui
5 jours il y a le coup des billets
gratuits pratiquement parce qu'on paye
un France symbolique et tu penses quoi
toi la situation du cinéma aujourd'hui
en fin les charges le business du cinéma
aujourd'hui mais les salles de cinéma je
trouve qu'il y a plein de choses à faire
c'est bien parce que les choses bougent
moi je viens de tourner un film en
Italie je sais qu'en Italie ça marche
pas mal mais ça marche moins bien j'ai
qu'en France les choses bougent pas mal
dire qu'on a toujours on est toujours
plus cinémater en prises mais quand même
il y a des choses qui marchent et je
trouve que la qualité revient quand même
la qualité marche c'est-à-dire qu'on a
divisé les salles d'abord maintenant on
retrouve on refait des grandes parce
qu'on s'aperçoit que le cinéma pour
faire sortir les gens de chez eux c'est
vrai que
[Musique]